my name is emily riehl i'm a
mathematician at johns hopkins
university in baltimore
and i work on infinite dimensional
category theory
bill thurston has this really lovely
essay on proof and progress in
mathematics
and he points out that progress in
mathematics is made not just through
proving new theorems
but also through advancing human
understanding of mathematics
so there are some theorems that i've
proven that i'm very proud of but i'm
also proud of the work that i've done on
expository writing
i've written some textbooks trying to
communicate the mathematics that i love
to a broader audience than i'd be able
to in a research paper alone
so in an orchestra there are instruments
that sound spectacular
individually and they're often given the
soloist roles
what the viola contributes is it really
adds a layer of depth
to the sound it's tying together the
high pitches and the violins and the
low tones and the bases
you know frankly i think uh the pieces
sound like garbage if you don't have the
viola
in there and similarly category theory
is adding depth by recognizing
connections between theorems that are
proven in abstract algebra and
theorems that are proven in points at
topology category theory recognizes that
a mathematical argument that's
discussing quite different objects
can be sort of fundamentally the same
[Music]
i think it's important for
mathematicians to recognize that
not all of our students have exactly the
same background
some of us fell in love with mathematics
at a very
young age and others they'll discover
their
passion for mathematics much later in
life some people are very comfortable
using the lingo that you pick up if
you're hanging out with the
kids in the math common room whereas
others never felt quite as welcome in
that space and don't speak quite the
same language
so one of the things that i think about
a lot as an educator
is whether the language i'm using would
alienate the students in my classroom
who haven't understood
everything that i've said quite yet and
we're really
very narrow-minded if we think that
everything that we say is
absorbed immediately by whoever is
listening